-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night." We hope
you're doing well tonight.
Now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
While speaking yesterday at the
White House's tribal summit,
President Biden discussed
his high school football career
and claimed to have been
the runner-up
in the state
scoring championship.
Well, I don't know
how to tell you this,
but runner-up
isn't good enough!
[ Laughter ]
The Republican National
Committee held its fourth
and final presidential debate
last night in Alabama.
And based on what I saw,
here are my predictions.
Fox News morning show.
Couple books nobody will read.
"Dancing with the Stars."
Steps in a bucket
and the bucket
gets stuck on his foot
and he falls off the porch.
[ Laughter and applause ]
During last night's
Republican debate,
entrepreneur Vivek Ramaswamy
expressed support
for several conspiracy theories,
including the far-out idea
that Vivek Ramaswamy
could become president.
[ Laughter ]
House Republicans yesterday
rejected Hunter Biden's
offer to testify publicly
in front of Congress
as part of the impeachment
inquiry into President Biden,
and have threatened
to hold him in contempt
if he does not appear in
a closed-door session.
In Hunter Biden's defense,
you get him behind closed doors,
things tend to get
a little freaky.
[ Laughter ]
In a post this week
on Truth Social,
former president Trump
said he directed Eric Trump
not to testify again in the
$250 million civil fraud trial
because, you know,
he just saw him at Thanksgiving.
[ Laughter ]
Former Pennsylvania Senator
Rick Santorum
said in a recent interview
that at least two
Republican presidential hopefuls
have reached out to him
for advice.
On what? A concession speech?
[ Laughter ]
Lawmakers in Russia
recently set a date
for the country's
next presidential election --
Februvember 40th.
[ Laughter ]
A deer rose --
A deer recently --
A deer recently
broke into an elementary school
in New Jersey --
and this is embarrassing --
won a spelling bee.
[ Laughter ]
This kid's good.
The roof of a double-decker bus
in England
was recently ripped off
after it hit a low bridge,
and passengers were relieved
because they came this close
to having to finish the tour.
[ Laughter ]
And if you look to your left,
you'll see an old wall
made of stones.
[ Laughter ]
I laughed harder when I read
that than they collectively did
when I said it.
[ Laughter ]
Then I do "wall of stones,"
standing ovation.
[ Laughter ]
Wait for them to calm down,
move on to the next joke.
[ Laughter ]
According to new data,
fewer Americans
are working from home.
Turns out they're mostly
just dicking around on the web.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, guy who wrote
that joke for me?
Working from home.
[ Laughter ]
There he is.
Authorities in New Jersey
were recently called to capture
a loose pig named
Albert Einswine...
[ Laughter ]
...after it escaped
from its home.
It was caught safely and
reunited with his brother,
Sloppenheimer.
[ Laughter ]
Same guy wrote that joke.
Maybe less dicking around
on the web, Brian.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe you come back to work.
Look me in the [bleep] eyes
when you write these jokes.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe not click send.
And finally, a cargo ship
yesterday broke down
in Egypt's Suez Canal
and crashed into a bridge.
And you're not
going to believe this.
Everything you just bought
for your family
for the holidays was on it.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
We've got a great show
for you tonight.